the basic idea is that you know an
ellipse is an oval shape the distance
from the center to the vertices that
distance we call a and it's going to be
either elongated in the vertical
Direction like stretched in the vertical
direction or in the horizontal direction
okay but the distance from the center to
the vertex the vertex vertices are gonna
be on that longer axis that's called a
major axis so in this case this is the
major axis this is the major axis over
here and then the minor axis that's
going to be the narrower direction and
the distance from the center to the co
vertex or the minor vertex we call that
distance B and then the distance from
the center to the foci we call that
distance C and it's all tied together
with this equation C squared equals a
squared minus B squared okay kind of
like Pythagorean theorem but you're
subtracting and then the general form of
the equation of ellipse is this guy
right here notice the h and the K picks
up the graph and it shifts it left and
right up and down but it has the
opposite effect so if it's X minus 2
you're actually shifting right - if it's
y plus 3 you're actually shifting down 3
ok that always equals 1 and then with
these denominators the a is always going
to be greater than B okay so just FYI
these can actually switch ok their
position and then the last thing is
talking about the eccentricities
eccentricities just gives you an idea
about how round the ellipses or how like
narrow and stretch you know and thin the
ellipses and the formula for
eccentricity is equal to C divided by a
so the distance to the from the center
to the focus divided by the distance
from the center to the vertex and an
easy and fun way to kind of remember
this is that the eccentricity for an
ellipse is in between 0 and 1 the closer
the eccentricities to 0 the more the
ellipse looks like a 0 so like a circle
okay like the like the number 0 and the
closer gets to 1 the you know more
stretched and thin it is it looks more
like the number 1 so you can kind of see
you know that's an easy way to kind of
remember you know what you're dealing
with when you're dealing with
eccentricity so before we get into this
example let me just mention that if
you're preparing for the AC T or the SAT
check out my huge a CT math review video
course and my huge SAT math review video
course I go through a number of
different concepts together with you we
go through example problem
there's a teaching section there's
opportunities for you to practice and if
you're prepared for that test and you
really want to boost your score a lot of
students have found a great benefit from
that so check out those courses but
let's go to this problem now and see if
we can solve it so they're giving us the
vertices are at plus or minus nine comma
zero so I always like to draw a sketch
just so I can see what we're dealing
with right
so plus or minus nine so we're going
right nine okay so I'll just write nine
zero so that's our vertex right there
and negative nine zero right so that's
our other vertex over here and the
eccentricity is two-thirds
now remember eccentricity is equal to C
divided by a so you can see we have a
little bit of an equation here that we
can work with the distance from the
center to the vertex this distance right
here remember is is our a and you can
see that a is equal to nine so if we put
nine in here we get two-thirds is equal
to C over nine right and if we multiply
both sides by nine you can see that C is
going to be equal to eighteen thirds
which is six okay so now we know what a
is it's nine we know it C is its six we
can solve for B by using this equation
right here C squared equals a squared
minus B squared so let's go ahead and do
that so we've gotten C squared equals a
squared minus B squared C squared would
be 6 squared which is 36 a squared is 9
squared which is 81 minus B squared and
let's see if we subtract 81 we get a
negative 45 equals a negative B squared
multiply both sides by negative one and
you can see that B squared is 45 if we
take the square root that's going to be
around less than seven okay so it's
gonna be somewhere around here and
around here so we can kind of get an
idea about the shape of our ellipse
something like this okay but we're
really after the equation in this
problem so let's take a look so it's
centered right at the origin so we don't
have to worry about the h and the K H
and K are going to be 0 this equation is
going to be x squared plus y squared
equals 1 and you can see we're going
nine to get to the vertices in the X
direction so that's going to be 9
squared is 81 and then in the Y
direction we're going to square root of
45 this is our B squared value and
that's going to be 45 so
that was a kind of a whirlwind tour on
how to solve for the equation of ellipse
when you're giving the eccentricities C
over a and the vertices so I hope that
helped you understand how to work with
these a little bit better if it was kind
of confusing definitely check out the
other videos that I did talking about
ellipses I'll have links for that for
you subscribe to the channel check out
more videos on my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon